>> YO, THIS COUNTRY MAN OR
WOMAN.
IT'S CRAZY.
CRAZY.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ONLY LIKE ONE
LADY HOLDING THE WHOLE DAMN
THING TOGETHER, RIGHT?
AND YOU THINK SOME BROKEN RIBS
ARE GOING TO KEEP HER DOWN?
HELL NO, AND HELL NO.
>> LIVE GINSBURG AND I RIDE.
>> THIS IS YOU, RBG.
♪♪♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE FOR GINSBURG
OKAY LIVE GINSBURG
FOR GINSBURG OKAY ♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE
FOR GINSBURG OKAY ♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE
FOR GINSBURG OKAY ♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE
FOR GINSBURG ♪
♪ HER NAME'S RBG
AND SHE BORN IN BK
RUNNING THE SUPREME COURT
KILLING IT SINCE 33 ♪
♪ SHE WENT TO
LAW SCHOOL
SHE WAS FIRST
IN HER CLASS ♪
♪ IF SHE EVER WANTS
A DATE I PLEAD
THE COURT ON
♪ SHE WAS OUT THERE
ON THE STRIP OKAY
TELLING TRUMP TO ♪
>> KISS MY BUNS!
♪ FIGHTING FOR
WOMEN'S RIGHTS
EQUAL RIGHTS
SHE THE ♪
♪ SHE WORK FOR PRESIDENTS
JIMMY CARTER BILL CLINTON
SHE'S EXPERIENCED AS
SHE SHOULD BE PRESIDENT ♪
♪ BECAUSE I LIVE
GINSBURG SO I RIDE
FOR GINSBURG ♪
>> WHERE BROOKLYN AT?
♪♪♪
♪ THE COURT IS THE STAGE
WRITE DISSENT THAT
THROWS SHADE ♪
♪ TELL TRUMP STAY OUT
HER WAY DON'T
WITH MY ROE V WADE ♪
>> PRECEDENTS.
♪ SUPREME COURTS A BOYS
CLUB SHE HOLDS IT DOWN
NO CARES GIVEN WHO ELSE
GOT SIX MOVIES ABOUT THEM ♪
♪ AND STILL LIVING
SHE'S BRASS KNUCKLES TOUGH
HER SCARED GOT TO
BE KIDDING ♪
♪ POUR ONE OUT FOR MY
RETIRED HOMIE ANTHONY
KENNEDY ♪
♪ SURVIVED THE DEPRESSION
AND TWITTER ATTACKS
FROM TRUMP ♪
♪ BROKEN RIB CAGE
STOP HER BEFORE
SHE EATS THAT
FOR LUNCH ♪
>> NOW YOU KNOW WHO I AM.
♪ SHE SNAPS ON THESE BARS
LIKE THE GINS AT A BAR EXAM
YA PUTZ ♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE FOR
GINSBURG ♪
♪ LIVE GINSBURG
AND I RIDE FOR
GINSBURG ♪
♪♪♪
>> NOW YOU KNOW WE LOVE RBG.
YO, TELL THEM YOUR FAVORITE RBG
DECISION DOG.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> COME ON!
MAN.